let me pull up this story and i'll show
you exactly what we're talking about
from u.s news justin trudeau seizes
emergency powers to curb protests
they report
prime minister trudeau invoked emergency
authorities monday to end demonstrations
that have paralyzed canada's capital and
beyond since late last month but he
assured canadians that he would not call
in the military quote this is about
keeping canadians safe protecting
people's jobs and restoring confidence
in our institutions blah blah blah we're
not suspending fundamental rights or
overriding the charter yeah yeah yeah
the move comes even as traffic began to
creep back to normal monday at one of
the continent's busiest border crossings
the emergencies act has rarely been used
and would give the federal government
extra powers to restore order
by ending the demonstrations
that is to say
peaceful protesters
who are demanding they be heard by their
government will be arrested will be shut
down
and that's it because the government
said so no redress of grievances just
just force by the authorities
and people are calling it martial law if
you're not familiar this is the great
honking truckers are protesting they're
saying we don't want these vaccine
mandates lift them trudeau says shut up
do as you're told you pathetic poor
and this is what they do yeah
the this is um
if you go to dc and you go to the
national archives and there's the
constitution there's the declaration of
abundance fascinating it's really cool
to see a real person a little bit off to
the side uh not centrally prominently
located is a copy of the magna carta
12 15
seven years ago should have had a much
bigger celebration than it did i thought
obama dropped the ball i thought the
world dropped the ball
but for the friend i'm gonna be nerd for
a second for the first time in the
history of mankind
power was ceded to this thing called the
law whereas up until now power was ceded
to other powers so so ian is the king um
you know but but if tim kills the king
now the power is seated to tim because
and the the the the nobility of england
said
you can't just say you're in charge
because you're in charge there has to be
something greater than you and it is the
law and one of the parts of the magna
carta is the petition of grievances and
and habeas corpus right and to say there
has to be able to you have to be able to
bring evidence against me you can't just
say i have declared that this is unjust
and because i am all power and we've
lived this way for 807 years and to get
little
trudeau to say
this is wrong because i have declared it
thusly
is abolishing
nine centuries of what makes
civilization civilization i mean it
really is an affront to humanity as we
have known it almost the last century
millennia because it destroys
the rule of law donald trump did not
invoke the insurrection act
when they were riding across the country
from small towns to big cities burning
down buildings
around 30 people dead donald trump said
i can't do it you know he wanted to do
it tom cotton said send in the troops
and trump would not do it
trudeau
seizing emergency powers promising not
to bring in the military but seizing
political power
why aren't they calling him a fascist
why wouldn't trudeau's cabinet or his
his advisors tell him as a first act why
don't you find the head trucker and just
say you know head trucker steve
why don't you just come to my office and
let's talk like
right that's too reasonable and you you
would think that canada of all places
would want to give the truckers what
they want people in america don't
realize how less densely populated it is
they need truckers way more than we do
they have very
like cities few and far between i i
really don't understand the logic here
no
the logic is
trudeau
probably views himself as
a better man and so when the unclean
poors are demanding us at the table he's
probably going oh
at my table
it's like the lord farquaad in shrek you
know
get that thing out of here
that's what it is he's not going to sit
down with lowly truckers
heavens because it would be so easy for
him to end this they're already talking
about ending the vaccine mandates he
could just be they've already talked
about saving face instead he's like i
what he wants is he wants people to know
it's his power yeah and he will wield it
against you regardless of your rights he
wants you scared
this is this is the desperation of the
state mainly in canada but we've seen it
here in the us in some forms
they're scared that if the people
realize they have the power because
government is for by and of the people
well the people might actually take
command and try and vote for things that
people want
but the establishment the uniparty the
powerful elites the banking interests
the corporate interests that work hand
in hand across country lines oh they
can't have that i don't know if her
majesty's a fan of your show i hope she
is um but she does have the authority to
dismiss her prime ministers who who who
are in her realm and i would i i kind of
wish you would step up and just say
trudeau like this is that would be
incredible
um the last time was uh
it hasn't been in a while it was
it was uh william the fourth so like 18
something but yes he did decide as a
prime minister but that was a uk
uk but but but she can all the other
prime ministers as well she can canada
australia new zealand like not not the
commonwealth but the
what do they call it the crown i guess
imagine being the queen of england
and having you know abdicated
responsibility for what's happening in
the commonwealth and done nothing
unless of course she supports it i think
she supports or maybe for all we know
she's the one who called trudeau and
says do as you're told and invoke the
act and shut it down maybe she did yeah
i think biden was involved too when
trudeau disappeared i started hearing
whisperings that he's been meeting with
other world leaders in there he did with
biden he did and biden promised to
intervene and help them yeah exactly so
now that's crazy how he's emboldened and
so what they're gonna do according to
some i don't know who this was i
listened to some prime some minister of
canada uh canada's deputy prime minister
said that they are broadening canada's
terrorist financing rules so that they
can cover crowdfunding platforms and
cryptocurrencies look at that check this
out check this out that's why we got get
rid of the dollar make everything
digital and we can control it from
timcast.com td bank freezes personal
bank accounts that received 1.1 million
in support for canadian truckers the
bank said it could not determine if the
money's donors were entitled to a refund
wow
he says he's not calling on the troops
but in a way economic siege is worse
like you could either stage troops
around the perimeter of someone's house
or you can just make sure the food no
longer gets in yeah
i mean this is just insanity and that's
that's the scary thing about
our digital information age is what you
guys are experiencing all the time um
we can just decide you can't have a bank
account you can't have a credit card you
can't have an uber account i mean there
are people right now who can't have uber
accounts heck uh um michelle malkin it
was banned from airbnb her family her
family you can't have an account on our
platform i feel like if we don't do
something real drastic or something
right now these people these truckers
are going to get thrown in the gulag
like these people on the 6th
yes yes absolutely they will the
canadian version that they're already
calling it an insurrection they're
saying it's like another january sixth
moment just like joe rogan's
they're saying it's a nationwide
insurrection yeah
but look
what the truckers are doing is exactly
what they they should be doing
and you know i i'll push back you can
you say something drastic no no nothing
drastic nothing drastic something simple
more truckers more people
peaceful you see
what we're seeing with them freezing
banks with invoking military powers i
you know why i love it so much it's
proving that the state the authorities
the elites don't know how to handle
peaceful protest because when you have a
violent protest or a riot people get
angry black lives matter lost a ton of
support when those riots happened
regular people are like we don't want
conflict
so when you get peaceful protesters in
trucks blocking things oh sure a lot of
people got met at the truckers in ottawa
and they're like you know i want to
drive
but to the average person in canada
they're probably like oh there's
peaceful protest what do you mean black
lives matter do the same thing blocking
the roads it's you know i'm not that
bothered by it when the state comes in
and starts cracking skulls
people start asking questions
during occupy wall street
i was i was there on like day three when
it started
it was very very tiny i remember
standing in the rain on like a thursday
and there was like 12 people in the park
almost nobody and we are under a big
tarp and this cop walks in and he's got
a raincoat on and he just looks at us
and he's like
man i respect what you guys are doing
and that was it because there was nobody
there it was like 12 people we're
standing around like so this is it huh
that weekend when a few thousand people
showed up to march
officer anthony bologna walked up to a
group of women standing on the sidewalk
and pepper sprayed them in the face for
no reason
the video at the time was said to be the
fastest viral video in the history of
youtube it got like 1.2 million views in
like 10 hours
all of a sudden occupy protests popped
up all over the country all of a sudden
people descended upon new york and there
was this massive you know occupation now
in the park why because when regular
people saw three women saying to the
cops like what are you doing why are you
doing this and the cop for no reason
just blasts him in the face regular
people got mad
when people see
non-violent civil disobedience peaceful
protesters saying respect me they're
like that's right you should respect the
working class and for trudeau to come
out and crush them would ignite a
massive wave that could go international
they can't do it so they're freezing
assets they're freaking out they're
trying to navigate this so i will stress
it again non-violent civil disobedience
works and it works so well trudeau has
seized emergency powers rarely if ever
invoked because they're panicking yeah
you know what's amazing is that for 170
years you've heard the cry workers of
the world unite since marx said it right
and you literally have the workers of
canada uniting and and the people who
wore
marx and engels t-shirts in college
they're now all in these positions to be
like crush them like this is a literal
workers protest and the elite who loves
socialism are like this cannot stand i
love the propaganda there was a meme on
reddit it was like front page and it
said thank you to the 90 of truckers who
are doing your jobs and delivering our
goods and i'm like oh you know i got to
be honest i'm willing to bet a lot of
the truckers who are still working still
support the other truckers oh yeah i'm
sure they do
i don't think when you thank them
they're probably like shut up
i'm working because i need to feed my
family but i respect what these guys are
doing that shows the disconnect they
don't care about the working class they
don't assume that the truckers that are
still trucking just literally needed to
obey to feed their family they just
assume that they agree with them because
they care about vaccinations that's it
yep
yeah this it's going to be curious to
see how that much more this escalates
and this use of power
to to to shut down uh uh you know bank
accounts and
it's it's going to get worse it's going
to get a lot worse and trudeau is too
stupid and too fearful to to control of
the situation the simple thing is you
know they they said it's a nationwide
insurrection okay
they're trying to make it sound like
january 6th but on january 6 you had
violence and they were able to use those
videos put them all over the place and
you get people freaking out about it
regular people who don't know better see
those videos and i don't have anything
to do with that but peaceful protests
call it an insurrection all you want
it's not going to work they're going to
keep panicking thanks for checking out
this segment from the tim cast irl
podcast if you want to watch live you
can check out this channel monday
through friday at 8 00 pm and don't
forget to smash that like button
subscribe to this channel and if you
want more unfiltered and uncensored
content with all of these guests go to
timcast.com and become a member all of
these guests you know and love in
exclusive segments on our website where
we are unrestricted in what we talk
about so you'll definitely not want to
miss it thanks for hanging out we'll see
you all next time
you